#HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
EVERYONE KNOWS ABOUT OSCAR
CATEGORIES LIKE BEST PICTURE,
BEST SUPPORTING ACTRESS.
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE OF IT
TO EXPLORE.
THAT'S WHY TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
NEW OSCAR CATEGORIES, NEW OSCAR
CATEGORIES.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE LEAST
PRONOUNCEABLE NAME, OR BEST
MOVIE YOU LIED ABOUT SEEING
BECAUSE YOU WANTED TO SEEM
INTELLIGENT, OR JENNIFERIEST
LAWRENCE WOULD BE ANOTHER ONE.
SO I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK, AND GO.
GRACE.
>> BEST AUDIBLE FART IN A DRAMA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: IS THAT A SEX FART OR
A REGULAR FART?
>> THE BEST WILL WIN.
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS!
YES, HANNAH?
>> BEST USE OF HASHTAG IN A
MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
>> Chris: POINTS!
MAMRIE?
>> LEAST WANTED SHOT OF A NAKED
MALE BUTT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON WHO THAT MIGHT BE?
>> I MEAN, THEY RUN THE GAMUT.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
>> REALLY, ALL MALE BUTTS.
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: GRACE?
>> BEST ACTOR WHOSE NAME RHYMES
WITH SADLY POOPER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> WHO KNOWS, WHO KNOWS?
>> Chris: HANNAH?
>> BEST USE OF A CAT MOTIF BY
YOUTUBE STARS.
>> Chris: YES!
SELF REFERENTIAL.
>> ♪ PLUG IT IN
PLUG IT IN. ♪
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THAT.
YOU GUYS MADE A MOVIE.
YES, MAMRIE?
>> LEAST OFFENSIVE THING SAID
THAT PEOPLE WILL TAKE OFFENSE TO
THE NEXT DAY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: GRACIE?
>> BEST KEY GRIP TO CONVINCE
BRUCE DERN TO ACCEPT MY FACEBOOK
REQUEST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WHY WON'T HE ACCEPT IT?
WHAT'S HE WAITING FOR?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'VE SENT HIM NUMEROUS DICK
PICKS.
(LAUGHTER)